chapter five inclusive stakeholding
realize that everything connects to
everything
else leonardo da vinci
mycelium is the neurological network of
nature
paul stamets
mycorrhizal networks 95
of all plants work with fungi
underground in a two-way resource
exchange
mother trees that sequester more carbon
and produce more sugar from
photosynthesis
nurture smaller trees in the understory
even those of different species
we need similar biomimicry in our social
contracts for us to get through the ai
age today most people
feel a stark difference between the
inclusive fitness
of their mother versus the high fructose
corn syrup
being peddled to our limbic
infrastructures
by self-dealing corporations
total job space robots
will be able to do everything better
than us
i am not sure exactly what to do about
this
this is really the scariest problem to
me elon musk
whatever you are studying right now if
you are not getting up to speed on deep
learning neural networks etc you lose
we are going through the process where
software will
automate software automation will
automate
automation mark cuban
since 1971 in the usa
median male income decoupled from real
gdp
per capita for 50 years people have been
experiencing exclusive stakeholding
where a small class of globalizing elite
reap the benefits of an increasingly
technologizing planet
the solution isn't ubi universal basic
income
it's ubs universal
basic stakeholding where we leverage
mechanism design in our social contracts
that biomimic nature so that we
all become wealthy
june yoon has an ongoing crowdsourcing
project
for these next generation architectures
before
usa's 250th birthday
in 2026.
my contribution to it is a project
i created alongside high level
perception
called rich patrons you can find that at
rich patrons.com
which aims to provide a trusted
avenue for unlocking the six to ten
trillion
u.s dollars from ultra high net worth
individuals and families to focus
on inclusive stakeholding architectures
to tackle projects
like the sdgs
humanities last refuge for now from the
tornado of
ai automation are creative rube goldberg
moments of
genius that only happen once like the
formation of a powerful idea
self play a i plays against itself
to improve exploring novel creative
permutations
faster than humans merging is not
only the most ideal future solution
it's likely precisely where we came from
before the big
bang gigi good game